my advice would be if you are
thinking if you are thinking of
applying for a deposit position ok
oprah postgraduate
sure you should contact the
researcher you are going to be
associated with during these next few
years but also the other
postgraduate students  and the postdoc associated with
this laboratory
after all in the coming years you
will live this experience in having
contact with what the academic environment is like
you will succeed in these years it is super
important
this is an excellent moment to be able to
submit your proposal for study or study
neither do I research
because the Brazilian government has
encouraged and has exports it has given
funding for students to be
here
for example I'm here with a
scholarship from fapesp which is a
research agency a development agency of the
state of são paulo is  the thing I'm going to
talk about is the phrase that my two
and a half year old son tells me daddy don't worry
i don't think anyone has to worry  you do
n't need it and it's not a seven-
headed thing not this ivory tower that
everyone thinks or this thing that you
can't reach that is beyond
your reach
in fact it is a place that values
diversity a place that will be here
in arms  open waiting to
provide the best education in the world
i hope you get this
message and i really come here i
hope you